joining us here is uh a man whose work i
truly love and enjoys one of the best
sports columnists out there whether it's
on a game day like saturday's michigan
ohio state game or on a day like today
to give us perspective on the college
football world uh yahoo columnist yahoo
sports columnist dan wetzel back here on
the show how are you dan
i am i'm well uh rich not as well as you
you uh michigan uh people are having
yourself a moment aren't you well you
could peel us off the ceiling well
deserved it's well earned i appreciate
that you know and all the ohio state uh
friends of mine and fans of mine um
always told me that a win over michigan
always gets better than each passing day
now i'm getting that sense back after
not having felt it in quite some time
and um and i had no idea that on top of
it my uh my complete disdain for notre
dame would be fed in the manner of the
winningest coach in the history of their
of that uh esteemed program saying lsu
is better why why did uh why did brian
kelly say that is it money is it really
just that what is it dan
no it's um
it's it's a shot to win a national title
and and this is where we're at in
college football it's it's
uh i mean this is a this is an
incredible move by
by kelly because
there are four games this weekend that
that matter and who gets in the playoffs
and
notre dame needs like one or two results
none of which are out of the out of line
and they would be in the playoff on
sunday
if georgia beats alabama and either
cincinnati loses michigan loses or or
oklahoma state loses
which again very possible notre dame's
gonna get in this playoff and brian
kelly would have a playoff team
for the third time in four seasons and
this isn't like the nba playoffs there's
only four teams in the playoff okay
and so everything we've ever been told
by coaches
teams we're all in we can do it nobody
believes in us we you know just give us
a shot we'll rise up brian kelly is
staring at that possibility
and saying yeah
i'm out
i don't care
we don't have a shot or we don't i'm not
even going to try
and he's bailing on a potential team if
he made this move on so if notre dame
doesn't get in and he makes this move on
sunday totally get it
but the fact he's doing it
now is just like
like you know i said like the sequel to
rudy is horrible like this is this is
not what we were going for here um
it's just everything against sports so
he's making that move but the crazy part
of the sport is he's looking and saying
i have a better chance of winning a
national championship i'm 60 years old
i'm a very very good coach
i have a better chance of winning a
national championship by going and
taking over
an lsu program that is 500 the last two
seasons
than actually coaching in the playoffs
this year
with a program that is 44 and six over
the last four would make their third
playoff appearance
that's how
important it is to have the elite elite
level recruits
that you can get at lsu
but you just can't really get at notre
dame well i mean that's where the
sport's at well part of that may be you
know the provost that's there in south
bend and you know
notre dame has definitely has different
aspects of their program that other
schools around the country certainly
like lsu i don't believe have
so i i kind of see all that but the the
question i have is was there a a take it
or leave it you've got 24 hours 48 hours
deal on the table for brian kelly why
why wouldn't he play this thing out
because if he did play it out to see if
they have a a college football playoff
that certainly lsu wouldn't wait four
more weeks to fill their role right
there's there's recruiting that's going
on
right now dan
it it seems we will find out more uh
when as this hashes out but it would
seem like you had to make that move
right now you at least wait five days
right
um but
the nature of this thing is is
everything moves very very fast uh and
there is there's recruiting signing days
in two weeks they very foolishly created
an early quote unquote signing day which
totally sends this every year into
tumult and has kids signing with
programs that don't even have coaches
terrible idea but they do it um but i i
would guess lsu said you take this off
for now or not and we'll go we'll go in
another direction and brian kelly took
it we'll we'll see though um
it happened very very quickly brian
kelly was in a in a recruits home
recruiting for notre dame yesterday
they walked out took the job come on and
then tried to fly home come on
are you serious
yes
it's close to the all-timer which was
when tommy tuberville was at texas tech
and was at a meeting at a recruiting
dinner with a family
took a call accepted the cincinnati job
and then just left just ghosted them in
the restaurant love it
the all-timer but this is close um
wow dan i've got one for you on the
opposite side of that spectrum rod
woodson my buddy pro football hall of
famer told me that when he was recruited
mr indiana and football coming out of
the great state of indiana that we're
talking about right now um that uh lee
corso was the coach of indiana football
and recruited him thusly showed up to
his front door
said rod i've just been fired as head
coach of indiana football but you should
still go there it's a great place
that's why he did it
and thus he went to purdue because he
wanted to stay at home you know
it's unbelievable that's i guess maybe
the opposite end of that that would be
the opposite it was a more uh simpler
time and that is a course it was a great
man
i'll tell you this dan let's let's move
let's have this conversation this is a
different sport now of course but let's
let's have that conversation that dan
wetzel of yahoo here on the rich houses
show i don't want to hear another human
being
complain when a college football player
does not play in his bowl game because
there's nothing quote unquote left to
play for and we're supposed to sit here
and say you got to play for the school
you got to play for your pride you got
to play for your your teammates when
they've got an nfl career going and and
college football head coaches are
showing up and recruiting somebody in
their house
and then saying i'm out he has every
right to do that and he's doing this for
his family in his career what about
players this is professional sports now
dan yeah well fortunately they finally
gave up
uh on the trans and allow the transfer
portal and that took years and years of
a lot of yelling at college athletics to
allow that but at least the players can
lead too
uh and they can leave right after i mean
lincoln riley he wasn't recruiting hours
before he took a job he was literally
coaching to get in the big 12
championship game right
walks out of the locker room and
basically takes the usc job um
so all this stuff happens and at least
now the players can also leave they
they're all free to go and they can go
somewhere else
and and play next season there's no
sitting out uh but clearly the the that
charade that that the loyalty had to be
one way or in in only one way was always
outrageous and it becomes more and more
outrageous as it goes brian kelly has
every single right to go take whatever
job he wants and he did
the player should have the right to go
hey i want to follow him or i only came
to notre dame for this reason or i want
to go whatever school i want to go to
now
so it's got to be a two-way street and
at least now we're on that path where it
isn't you race through dan wetzel yahoo
sports here on the rich eisen show you
have any ear to the ground on who
notre dame might be looking at to to
fill in
this role right now obviously
temporarily if not large what do you got
for me yeah it's fresh because they
weren't expecting it um literally a week
ago brian kelly sat in front of the
uh
media and discussed you know basically
said he was he had the same belief as
mike tomlin and said only a quarter
million
a quarter billion dollar deal would get
him away a 250 million dollar deal he
got about 95 to 100 million so
um notre dame was not expecting this
look the guy they want is luke fickle
the cincinnati coach luke fickle is a
different guy i
look at never say never
you can't be cynical enough in this
profession but i cannot imagine luke
fickle walking away from his team
certainly if they make this playoff
um
like brian kelly just did i just i just
can't i cannot fathom him doing that
that the type of guy is luke fickle's
the perfect hire there he is a midwest
guy he is an ohio guy
ohio state has a coach for the long term
uh you know
other jobs in the area that maybe
michigan now isn't looking to open penn
state just has a big deal so if he wants
to stay notre dame is a possibility for
luke fickle but i also could see look
fickle just saying i'm good i'm gonna
stay at cincinnati we're going in the
big 12 all that marcus freeman their
young
defensive coordinator
highly highly regarded has done
incredible work this year with the
defense
and in recruiting
he has no head coaching experience as a
very challenging job notre dame is a
tough job so that would be there and
then you have you know the matt
campbell's or somebody like that
who's done a pretty good job at iowa
state those are probably your three most
likely you could get nfl interest you
could get a lot of different people but
notre dame's scrambling right now and i
don't know that they can even get luke
fickle on the phone
uh to find out whether he's interested
but if cincinnati wins on saturday i
think he's off the table if if
cincinnati loses on saturday now maybe
he got a shot at luke sickle well i mean
while we're being cynical uh the dots
being connected with urban meyer um
having a very difficult time
in his first year yes you already said
no way i mean he's already gotten as
many losses in jacksonville this year
that he had at ohio state his entire
tenure there he's already got nine and
we're only entering week 13 in this nfl
season we know his uh affinity for the
place he's
uh he he was there in his uh coaching um
whistle stop tour that's led him to
jacksonville
no way you just said the words no way
right
yeah look
the urban meyer wins
urban meyer is a
a
high maintenance drama it's going to end
ugly
there's going to be it's everything
notre dame doesn't want to be
um would he win yes could he recruit and
and and deal with the job of under the
under the
all the different things that go on at
notre dame the some of the academic
restrictions the little things freshmen
have to live on the dorm right
freshmen they want their player the
players have to live with the other
students they have to eat in dining
commons with other students except for
training
urban wants a 24-hour sealed off
football program like he's a terrible
fit for notre dame
a terrible fit other than he would win
he could have had notre dame
years ago and he took he took florida
because he knew that would fit better i
mean i if notre dame did that it would
be
they would probably win but i don't know
i just that he is just not offended
notre dame urban is a very very good
college football coach a great college
football coach but it's all got to be
under his terms and it's going to burn
out really quick
you know and i i just he's just not that
guy that noted her name brian kelly was
pushing it at notre dame and pushed and
pushed to get change and and and
invariably couldn't so i i i don't think
urban meyer has got to got a shot at
this thing i don't think notre dame
wants him i don't think they want to win
that desperately
um to take urban buyers certainly not
the administration and all of that
last one for you then the the timing of
all this um
you said it seems like oklahoma's
president said we wish we had more of a
heads up notre dame seems to be caught
flat-footed
but james franklin who was rumored to be
wanting if not uh on the list of both of
these jobs that were filled by lincoln
riley and
and uh and brian kelly he signs a
contract last week to stay at penn state
if if he has an inkling that those jobs
are not going to be his
why didn't the schools that lost their
coaches know that their coaches were on
those wish lists
doesn't everybody talk
i mean seriously and these contracts
these contracts i had fun with it a
little bit on twitter and earlier on dan
wetzel if you watch succession and the
and the terms that the roy family
accepted to maintain control of way star
royco they're worse than what lincoln
riley got from usc you know i mean tech
with private jets and everything so it's
not like these these deals can just be
done over 24 hours you know they have to
there has to be a lot of talk behind the
scenes here i think uh
you know lincoln riley and and brian
kelly the same agent uh i think a good
agent can can do a lot of stuff quietly
who's the agent who's the agent who's
the agent well
we'll get to that but he but if you do
the thing
the right if you do it because i don't i
don't know i don't know all the details
went down okay but i don't know brian
look
james franklin
his name's out there he gets the deal he
also finished two and five
um
i don't know how hot of the candidate he
was going to end up being right but yeah
you you have to talk to your coaches and
try to keep them
in the past
people never left a a so-called blue
blood program for another blue blood
program i mean nobody nobody ever
willingly left oklahoma
or notre dame i think the last time a
guy left notre dame was like 1907 and
and it was pre-bud wilkerson that anyone
left oklahoma you got those jobs you
stayed
you did tom osborne you're joe paul you
did bear bryant you did foe and woody
you did you didn't leave unless you got
old or fired or their scandal you stayed
at those places and tried to win
and stayed and said hey over the next 20
years maybe we can win one
nowadays
the
pressure to get the elite recruits
because recruiting is so much better of
a science it's way more like an nfl
draft
and the top schools that can attract
them
get such a talent advantage people look
and say well there's a five stars a four
star is not that big of a difference no
one would ever say that in the nfl draft
a five-star recruit is like a
first-round draft pick
and only
there's only 250 guys about get drafted
a year if you're outside that 250 in the
nfl
you're an undrafted free agent those
guys nobody thinks about them
it's like georgia right now has six
five-star recruits committed for next
year that's six first-round draft picks
how are you beating that team if you
don't have any first-round draft tickets
so the ability to get to those schools
that can get that player and that's lsu
is so enormous because it's probably the
only way you can actually beat the top
there's only a few schools that can win
it right now and that's what brian
kelly's chasing but everyone else and
that's what lincoln riley was chasing
he's saying i got a better shot
because southern california has a ton of
great players oklahoma has produced one
five star one top 30 player since 2007
one kid and you end up going to michigan
daxton hill from tulsa but that's it so
you have to be able to get the elite
elite elite player to win football the
same way
a team that never gets a first round
pick is going to struggle in the nfl
dan great stuff as always love reading
your material um and and having these
conversations with you greatly
appreciate it let's do it down the line
please any time thanks again that's dan
what's up this weekend yeah i will do my
best to do so thanks again that's dan
wetzel right here from yahoo sports
national columnist of yahoo sports at
dan wetzel on twitter follow him read
his material hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here